i have a square here divided into one
two three four five six seven eight nine
equal sections
and we've already seen that if we were
to shade in one of these sections if we
were to select one of these sections
let's say the middle one right over here
this is one out of the nine equal
sections so if someone said what
fraction of the whole does this purple
square represent well you would say well
that represents
that represents one-ninth of the whole
this thing right over here represents
one-ninth now what would happen if we
shaded in more than that
so let's say we shaded in this one
and this one let me shade it in a little
bit better and this one
and
this one right over here
now what fraction of the whole have we
shaded in
well each of these we've already seen
each of these represent one-ninth so
that's a ninth that's a ninth when i say
one ninth i could also say a ninth so
this is one ninth or a ninth so each of
these represents a ninth but how many of
these ninths do we have shaded in well
we have one two three four shaded in so
now we have a total of four ninths
shaded in four of the nine equal
sections are shaded in so four ninths of
the whole is shaded in
now let's make things a little bit more
interesting
let's shade in so here i have five equal
sections let me write this down i have
five equal sections and let me shade in
let me shade in five of them so one
two
three
four
5.
we already know that each of these
sections each of these situated in
sections represent a fifth
so one-fifth another way of saying that
is a fifth
is one-fifth but now how much do i have
shaded in well i have five out of the
five equal sections shaded in or i have
five fifths shaded in and you might be
saying wait wait if i have five out of
the five equal sections shaded in if i
have five fifths shaded in i've got the
whole thing shaded in and you would be
absolutely right five-fifths is equal to
the whole
now what i want you to do is pause this
video and write down on a piece of paper
at least think in your head what
fraction of each of these holes is
shaded in
so let's go to this first one
we have one two three four five six
equal sections
six equal sections and we see that one
two three four are shaded in so four
sixths of this figure is shaded in
let's go over here we have one two three
four five six oh sorry one two three
four five equal sections
five equal sections and one two three
four shaded in so here four fifths of
this circle is shaded in
now in this figure i have two equal
sections
two equal sections and both of them are
shaded in
so two
and this we would say two halves of this
figure are shaded in and once again if
two halves are shaded and that means
everything is shaded in that a hole
that the whole that this represents a
hole
now this one right over here it might be
tempting to say hey i have one two three
four sections and one two three have
been shaded in so maybe this represents
the red represents three fourths of the
figure but remember the sections have to
be equal sections and this red section
is way bigger it actually looks like
it's bigger than the other three
combined so you do not have four equal
sections here so at least based on how
it's drawn you can't say that three
fourths is actually filled in